neoliberalism is a very contested
concept and it's an odd concept because
it's the term neoliberalism is mostly
used by people who don't like it new
liberalism happened very suddenly it was
carrying a lot of new perspectives
unknown outcomes but everybody suspected
that it was going to be big there was an
important economic crisis in the 1970s
around the sometimes called the oil
crisis but it also led to high levels of
state deficit and debt and out of those
cried that crisis of the 1970s there
began to be a new set of political ideas
which said that the state is doing too
much it's spending too much the deficits
exist because we're spending too much
therefore we have to cut back the role
of the state neoliberalism represents a
break with previous ideas about the
relationship between markets and States
it's involves a considerable change
some people argue even revolutionary
change in the sorts of societies that
have developed in the West primarily
since the Second World War and so the
neoliberal reforms that started in the
in the late 70s and 80s
many people believe started to dismantle
some of the foundations of those
post-war successes at a political level
of course it reflects a set of policies
that are oriented towards deregulation
privatization making markets more
competitive at an economic level really
neoliberalism represents the opening of
markets the making of markets more
competitive many of the phenomena that
we associated with globalization
neoliberalism is important as a set of
ideas at the cultural level
it has brought to the fore new ways of
thinking about people thinking about the
worth of what they're doing and in many
ways it's changing what we could think
of as a very self concepts of ordinary
people individuals are expected to
become to be fully self-sufficient to
pull themselves by their britches and
are not supposed to count on the state
or anyone else to ensure that their
prosperity and it has tremendously
impacted in in different ways that many
societies in all continents we live in
societies that have much greater
inequality today than they did 10 or 20
years ago I think this is one of the
fundamental challenges we face if we
want to continue to be a successful
society we need we need to very directly
address these growing inequalities and
particularly their their social and
cultural consequences